one more time to try for you for you
okay you like season two is darker yes
it's darker I don't I don't literally i
bracing about it is darker okay rolling
up and we're getting into more intense
situations so first of all thank you for
doing this with us
no of course thank you for having me how
are you doing right now with all of all
of this news and all of this stuff in
self quarantine life I mean it's it's
always so hard to wake up in the morning
and look at the news and read everything
but I just I keep my family and everyone
stays safe and healthy and I just I hope
that everyone can do their part and
staying home keeping others safe because
I'll be on the phone with my
grandparents I'm like you guys don't go
to the grocery store just let me get my
uncle to like bring you stuff and
they're like no we'll be fine and I
don't think they understand how severe
everything could be in the possibility
of what could happen if they do go out
because it's like this is miscible
danger well I think that's the hard
thing to write is a lot of our
grandparents aren't understanding the
severity of what's going on are you able
to see your parents right now like who
are you we're all we're all in different
places I'm in LA my mom isn't stuck in
Washington and my dad's down in Cabo and
my grandparents are in Seattle and my
other grandparents are in Idaho so we're
all just spread out and wish I was with
everyone else say how challenging is
that for you kind of being on your own
during all of this is it hard is it kind
of nice to get that knee time um I hope
my dog tank so it helps yeah I don't
like being alone yeah it's hard
what are you kind of doing to pass the
time I know that you started a virtual
book club I did I loved to read and so I
wanted to find something that could
bring so many people together and I feel
like that's a very good way to get lost
in a book and then be able to bring
whoever from wherever the world
and just do it together so I started
that and then just I'm working out a lot
I've been I have this rooftop that I had
my own private area and so I've just
been laying on the roof of my dog
tanning so what did he choose the book
that you chose for the first book it's
called we used to be friends right yes
well I was looking at different books
and my my friends recommended me this
book and they're like it's just really
cute why a book it has dual timelines
between two different girls so you get
to jump in to one's point of view and
the others and the timelines go in the
opposite direction so you're piecing all
these different puzzles together and
like why did they break up
why did why are they friends out and
when I was in high school I remember
just as you grew up you lose your
friends and some you become closer to
that you weren't close to in freshman
year and I just going back and reading
something like that I was like why I
feel like that almost sounds like a
storyline that we could see or yeah how
has this pandemic pandemic affected
production for you guys I only had to
halt production for a while HT on
everyone involved they're very they're
taking everything very seriously they
don't want to put their crew or their
past or anyone involved in harm and so
they just want to make sure everybody's
staying safe and healthy and and wait
for all of it to calm down where were
you guys in production because we did
see pictures of you at table reads we
were in the beginning okay so you know
where things go in season to them I do I
know I know I know I know
quite a bit but who knows we have many
months now where it could be getting
rewritten so do you think that's a
possibility that they're gonna I think
that they could of course tweak things
because there's time to tweak things
right now but I don't know what the
final outcome will be
is there a time jump of any sorts or do
you think things are gonna pick up
pretty quickly after this you
one finale no what I'm allowed to say
give us a hint we're done here
nothing nothing majorly jumps okay yeah
what new tease about Cassie's journey
and season 2 you won't even be able to
guess what's coming it I I did I
wouldn't I couldn't even guess it when
Sam called me over the summer going so
what do you think Austin's gonna do next
season like what do you think she's
gonna go and I'm like I don't know maybe
she was this or that he's like yeah yeah
no and then he read me a little bit I
was like oh my gosh wait I couldn't even
guess it so if anybody's able to guess
that you're very good oh it's shocking
in that she sort of does a 180 or just
shocking
it's just shocking I mean everything
went life for the teenager is shocking
so you never know what to expect
yeah is there a timeline kind of in the
back of all of your guys's heads of when
you think you could get back to work um
I think that everybody is really hoping
that it'll be sometime this summer but
they also don't want to rush anything
just in case it isn't safe so I I don't
think that they want to get too much
hope in all of our minds and then you
have to push it longer so we're kind of
just waiting and seeing but we're gonna
get season two first sure no matter what
yes yes don't worry Tori I really need
to know a big congrats in order for you
because you are Rihanna's savage ex
penty ambassador that's come about like
did Briana call you herself she had her
team reach out to me personally and
asked if I'd be interested in something
like that and I of course was and I
actually got asked to walk in her show
in New York but I couldn't sighs filming
another movie and it was the most
gut-wrenching experience I was so sad
but it was also just to be able to be
asked when you're five foot three like
I've never even thought that would be
able to be a possibility so being able
to dystopian
laughter and and just feels so powerful
in her lingerie and her clothing it's
amazing I love her pieces have you met
her have you worked with her have you
spoken I hope not yeah I have not met
her yet
okay I feel like that's gonna be so epic
and obviously I mean I think she's
probably a fan of euphoria and that's
why she thought you were so perfect oh
gosh I do love you for iya and I will
hopefully not fangirl and freak out when
I do gotta meet her so I do feel like we
like we're in Hollywood and so often we
get so caught up in appointments and
beauty and getting our hair done are you
sort of enjoying not having to deal with
that all right I love it
because especially on a show like
euphoria we constantly have so much heat
on our hair I'm costly having to color
my hair more blonde we have so much
makeup on and so being able to just let
my hair grow don't touch any heat on it
not wear any makeup my skin clears up
it's a really nice self-care moment yeah
I think that's also a nice message to
for all of the fans and like younger
girls who are watching them if they
realize how much makeup you guys are in
like what you guys are doing do you have
a message to them right now yeah of
course I mean even when I was younger
and I would watch TV and I would see
these girls with perfect skin and I
would have cystic acne and I would have
my face would be orange because I was
trying to cover up the acne and I didn't
know how it's not real like we won we
were tons of makeup to your CGI's even
if you do have pimples we do a pimple
path and they can correct all of that
out it's not real we have real skin like
I break out and I break out horribly and
and I just now this last year figured
out how to control my skin and I'm 22 so
don't expect to have clear skin don't
expect to look like anyone went on TV
because mostly it's not real I think
that's really nice to know and I know
knowing that
okay my last question is one more time
I'm gonna try for you for yeah I'm sure
you're like season two is darker yes
it's darker yeah I don't I don't
literally everything about it is darker
okay growing up and we're getting into
more intense situations so that's a good
team that was good we're good
[Music]